.
HER COMMENTS ABOUT THE COUNTRY
WILL INSPIRE ALL.
BUT FIRST, LET'S SEE...
WE'VE GOT VACCINE MANDATES, MASK
MANDATES, VACCINE PASSPORTS,
SOCIAL DISTANCING, NEW RULES
POPPING UP EVERYWHERE, FOR WE,
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AT THE
REQUEST OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR PARENT
SUPERVISORS IN THE CDC AND THE
NIH, THE CDC NOW SAYING THAT
EVEN IF YOU'RE FULLY VACCINATED,
YEAH, YOU CAN STILL GET COVID.
NIH IS ADVISING PARENTS TO WEAR
A MASK INSIDE THEIR OWN HOME.
WOW.
OKAY.
THE DELTA VARIANT, YES, IT'S
VERY SERIOUS, THEY TELL US.
I AGREE.
BUT FOR SOME REASON, THEIR
CONCERNS, THEIR MANDATES,
MAGICALLY, COMPLETELY, UTTERLY
DESPAIR WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
AS WE SPEAK, AT 25-YEAR RECORD
NUMBER OF LEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
POURING ACROSS THAT BORDER, MOST
ON VACCINATED, MANY INFECTED
WITH COVID-19.
IN FACT, 20% OF MIGRANT CHILDREN
NOW TESTING POSITIVE FOR COVID,
AN 18% OF FAMILIES.
THAT IS DOUBLE THE POSITIVITY
RATE IN THE ENTIRE U.S., BUT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION JUST CANNOT
BE BOTHERED TO FIND THE REAL
SOLUTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ONE HE
INHERITED AND GOT RID OF.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
TONIGHT -- ANY AMERICAN THAT
GETS COVID, ANY AMERICAN THAT
NEEDS TO BE HOSPITALIZED, GOD
FORBID, ANY AMERICAN THAT ENDS
UP DYING FROM COVID THAT IS
TRACED BACK TO JAIL'S OPEN
BORDERS, THAT IS JOE BIDEN'S
FAULT.
HE IS NOW OFFICIALLY PUTTING
AMERICAN LIVES AT RISK WITH HIS
OPEN BORDERS POLICIES, IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS PANDEMIC, AND
THEN DISPERSING PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY AND NOT TESTING MOST
OF THE PEOPLE AT ALL.
NO MANDATES FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, ONLY FOR AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
AND LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, WE ARE
SEVEN MONTHS INTO THIS CRISIS,
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC, AND
THIS IS WHAT OUR BORDER
FACILITIES LOOK LIKE RIGHT NOW.
MIGRANTS LITERALLY STACKED ON
TOP OF EACH OTHER IN SMALL ROOMS
AND JAIL CELLS, AND CAGES THAT
JOE BIDEN BUILT, UNTIL THEY
DISPENSE AND DISPERSE PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
AND GET THIS, ACCORDING TO A NEW
REPORT FROM "THE DAILY CALLER,"
AFTER DAYS PACKED IN THESE
OVERCROWDED BIDEN CAGES AND
FACILITIES, WELL, MIGRANTS ARE
ULTIMATELY THEN TRANSFERRED ON
PRIVATE, UNMARKED DEBTS TO
ABILENE, TEXAS, AND THEN LOADED
ONTO BUSES AND COMMERCIAL
FLIGHTS WITH DESTINATIONS ALL
ACROSS THE U.S. -- AGAIN, WITH A
HIGH RATE OF CODE POSITIVITY.
THIS IS MADNESS, BECAUSE IT IS
DRACONIAN MEASURES FOR YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, NO TESTING FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE BREAKING OUR
LAWS, NOT RESPECTING OUR
SOVEREIGNTY OR OUR BORDERS.
I GUESS THIS IS WHAT
AMERICA-LAST POLICIES LOOK LIKE.
ACCORDING TO WASHINGTON, ONE
OVERFLOW MIGRANT FACILITY WITH
MORE THAN A THOUSAND MIGRANTS
TRANSFERRED, THEY ARE NOW
EXPERIENCING WHAT IS A MASSIVE
COVID-19 OUTBREAK, ACCORDING TO
"THE SEATTLE TIMES," ARE THEY
CONSERVATIVE NEWS OUTLET, WHILE
THE GOVERNMENT RELEASED ABOUT
570 DETAINEES DEEMED AT HIGH
RISK FOR CONTRACTING COVID-19,
AND THE HARM IS DONE.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THE BORDER
CRISIS IS THE SINGLE LARGEST
NATIONWIDE SUPER-SPREADER EVENT
IN THE HISTORY OF THE U.S.
BUT THE COVID WARRIORS IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ARE
PRETENDING THE END OF THIS IS
HAPPENING.
NO CRISIS AT ALL.
I DON'T SEE ANY CRISIS HERE.
EVEN WORSE, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGING MIGRANTS TO COME BY
RAISING THE LIMIT ON REFUGEES,
ENDING THE VERY SUCCESSFUL-ERA
STATE-IN-MEXICO POLICY,
REINSTITUTING THE
CATCH-AND-RELEASE PROGRAM UNDER
OBAMA THAT DONALD TRUMP STOPPED.
NOW IT'S NOT EVEN
CATCH-AND-RELEASE, ITS
PROCESS-AND-RELEASE.
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN DISPERSED
ALL OVER THE U.S. WITHOUT SO
MUCH AS A COURT DATE.
OUR SYSTEM IS JUST NOT CAPABLE
OF PROCESSING THE OVER A MILLION
PLUS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT
HAVE ENTERED OUR COUNTRY SINCE
JOE BIDEN'S INAUGURATION.
BY THE WAY, THESE ARE THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, ONLY THE
ONES WE KNOW ABOUT, THAT WERE
ACTUALLY PROCESSED AND DETAINED
BRIEFLY BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SLIPPED ACROSS
UNDETECTED, BECAUSE ALL THOSE
RESOURCES PRETTY MUCH ARE IN
JUST A FEW AREAS.
AND TONIGHT OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LOVES TO SCOLD
FLORIDA, LOVES TO SCOLD TEXAS,
NOT TAKING COVID SERIOUSLY
ENOUGH.
WHY, BECAUSE GOVERNOR ABBOTT,
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, WON'T FORCE
ANYONE TO WEAR MASKS IN SCHOOL?
BUT GIVEN THIS CRISIS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, MIGRANTS PACKED
IN CAGES, SMALL ROOMS, NOT
TESTED, THEN DISPERSED
NATIONWIDE -- WHERE, IT'S
OBVIOUS, CLEAR, TRANSPARENT,
THAT JOE BIDEN DOESN'T REALLY
GIVE TWO ADAM SCHIFFS ABOUT THE
SPREAD OF COVID-19 UNLESS HE CAN
USE IT TO BLUDGEON HIS POLITICAL
ENEMIES OR BLAME TRUMP.
TO THAT END, IT APPEARS THA